news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so the state of nevada did something
very important yesterday
and after they did it donald trump
absolutely exploded in
another one of these fits of rage um
what nevada did
is they approved sending every
registered voter an absentee ballot
rather than sending out applications
which have to be returned
in order to get an absentee ballot
instead of saying simply if you want an
absentee ballot
you have to print and send us the
absentee ballot application
they uh had approved by the state
legislature
and expected to be signed into law by
the democratic governor
a bill which will say if you're a
registered voter we will send you
a ballot donald trump immediately took
to twitter to
furiously say quote in an illegal late
night coup
nevada's clubhouse governor made it
impossible for republicans to win the
state
post office could never handle the
traffic of
mail-in votes without preparation using
covid to steal the state see you
in capital c court now
it's actually a linguistic feat that
donald trump has accomplished
squeezing so many lies and distortions
into such a small number of characters
it's interesting that this is now
sort of the battle line when it comes to
the election
and how and when the november election
will take place has become one of the
biggest stories among many big stories
right now donald trump
first of all claiming that it is illegal
for nevada to do this it's not
states run their own elections they can
do this if they want they are not
sending absentee ballots as trump says
multiple ballots to the same people
or ballots to kids or uh undocumented
immigrants or whatever the case may be
ballots are going to registered voters
and states
have a right to do that secondly it is
not impossible for republicans to win
with mail-in voting in a literal sense
but donald trump seems to recognize that
in order to win he needs to suppress the
vote
and he disproportionately needs to
suppress the democratic vote
since democrats take the virus more
seriously than republicans if you make
it more difficult to vote or
at least more risky in terms of catching
the virus to vote
you will probably dissuade more
democrats than republicans from voting
it's a simple numbers game and the
polling i showed you yesterday bears
that out
democrats by taking coronavirus more
seriously
might be more likely to say if i have to
go in person i'll
i'm gonna stay home whereas republicans
because they are not taking the viruses
seriously are more likely to say if i
can't vote by mail
i will go in and vote so it's a strategy
and it's a very clear strategy
notice also that donald trump mentions
the post office can't handle the traffic
of mail-in ballots
he himself is trying to kneecap the post
office
he appointed as postmaster general a big
donor to his campaign louis de joy
louis de joy immediately decided to
restrict overtime for postal workers we
talked about it in detail earlier
and it looks as though louis de joy is
also starting to explore
the possibility of closing some post
office
branches so again trump citing problems
that he is
causing as the reason why we shouldn't
do something
and then lastly you know see you in
court
is is accurate in a sense and trump is
filing lawsuits
that might be a preview of what we can
expect in november depending on what the
results of the election
are we may see many elements
of this tied up in court and what trump
is essentially saying
is how can i possibly win if every
american is easily allowed to vote
without fear of catching the virus
that's fundamentally what this is about
it is completely authoritarian it is
completely anti-democratic and the
answer
is if everybody really is able to vote
safely
trump may not be able to win if you look
at the polling
and you look at the partisan split on
vote by mail versus vote in person
it is not a crazy suggestion to make
that if the will of the people is
accurately represented and not
hampered by kneecapping the post office
or preventing vote by mail
trump may not be able to win because
people want to vote him out now the
polling may change
and of course trump may suppress enough
of the democratic vote that he does get
re-elected but
he may accurately be perceiving that
although he wouldn't say it in those
words
now lastly uh this idea of the post
office
being unable to handle mail-in ballots
certainly
trump is trying to make it so that they
wouldn't be able to handle it but as it
stands today
the post office would be very well
equipped to handle mail-in ballots
the post office handles unconscionable
numbers of pieces of mail
and as long as we don't deliberately
destroy the post office which is what
trump is trying to do
the post office will have no problem
handling mail so fundamentally this
comes down to what is
one of the few strategies trump now has
to take control of the election i told
you
about that poll yesterday which showed
two-thirds of those planning to vote in
person are trump supporters
whereas 75 percent of those planning to
vote by mail
are biden supporters that is the data
which explains
why trump is so furiously against vote
by mail
trump's strategy is not to be a good
president so people want to vote for him
that opportunity has sadly come and gone
the strategy is suppress the vote
suppress the vote while kneecapping the
post office try to prevent vote by mail
in order to try to sneak into another
four years in office
we can't allow it to happen but we need
to vote in order to prevent it